our time on earth is ending
so we turn our gaze on road to discovery
new
in you food
[Music]
the new beginning
the mankind Oh sid meier you create such
wonderful soul-sucking entertainment
hi there in senior editor Kevin Van or
standing in for reviewer Nick Kappa
solely to tell you about sid meier's
civilization beyond Earth civilization
beyond Earth shifts the series brand of
turn-based discovery to another part of
the universe and the sci-fi setting puts
a slick chrome sheen on the old
addiction the basic formula however
remains the same you still situate your
capital city and click it to designate
the production of military units or
workers you still unlock new
technologies and cultural policies that
ensure a steady drip of upgrades so
despite the new trappings it's simple
enough to slide back into routine create
explore and expand there are a few
welcome touch-ups to smooth over
civilizations old edges and they first
appear in pregame as a series of
decisions to make prior to global
domination a first step can be taken
towards generating energy science
culture and so forth and you can begin
the game with a military unit or a
clinic if you'd prefer there's more
freedom afforded when picking out which
parcel of land to found your city on and
there is even a perk that reveals the
outlines of the world's land masses but
viable doesn't necessarily mean
welcoming this is an alien planet after
all and there are lessons to be learned
maybe those lessons will come from the
sand worm churning up your farmland or
maybe from the creature that's
three-quarters mandible just kind of
loitering ominously offshore aliens mess
with your early game plans utilizing
better cunning and more imposing units
than barbarians did in previous Civ
games a toxic miasma coats about a third
of the surface of any map damaging human
units and healing aliens natural wonders
are conspicuously absent which Rob's
part of the draw of exploring a new map
but the varied terrain is still full of
his creatures so-called affinities push
your development towards divergent goals
purity supremacy or harmony purity is
concerned with recreating the comforts
of Earth supremacy is a technocratic
gsella tree and harmony is for tree
huggers and lets you write an alien like
you would a horse it's a brave new world
but it's also just as cynical even the
most well-maintained alliances will be
shattered towards games end beyond Earth
portrays its advancements as new sticks
will use to Club each other over the
head in fact only the military gets
treated to any real illustration in the
game proper gone are the works of art
music and writing that helps to redefine
the cultural victory in civilization 5
pared back to an abstract number that's
ultimately used towards more aggressive
ends world wonders return but the
bonuses they offer are tepid and Samish
this time around there are quests though
a first for civilization they lend some
helpful narrative context to the action
and they can branch in unexpected ways
a newly founded independent outpost
might turn out to be performing
questionable experiments on its
colonists for example oh well there's
always old-fashioned battles military
units still hold sway over most of the
game space trading turn-based fire
between the hexagonal parcels of land
and besieging cities they fall back on
civilizations traditional archetypes
melee ranged cavalry and siege
even though outward appearances might be
as moon Rovers or monsters beyond
Earth's combat suffers from some issues
though cities are comically easy to take
most melee units fare quite well at city
capturing and you can often have a
city's defenses in a single attack this
results in situations where cities trade
ownership turn after turn a small
standing army is much more vulnerable
than it was
previous sips making it hard to get
invested in a unit when it can be easily
snuffed out by an orbital strike at any
moment by the end any semblance of
actual civilization goes out the window
as everyone else tries to drag all the
others down the three affinity specific
victories don't play out all that
differently nor it is a force concerned
with making contact with an unseen
advanced alien race and of course global
domination ever the crude way out
remains as tempting as ever when another
world leader shows up uninvited to talk
some smack this might be a foreign
planet but the comforts are still the
same a plot of lands and just one more
turn
[Music]